ce sont quasiment les seuls à avoir pu
reprendre les entraînements en salle
la section handisport du scalping
s'entraîne tous les jours de 11h à 17h
ouverte en 2015 elle rassemble des
joueurs avec différents handicaps
physiques
c'est vraiment à ces raisons que je joue
en handisport parce qu'en fait au final
pendant une dizaine d'années joueurs en
place vali c'est pas forcément le club
handisport et jallet que ça a été un
vrai plaisir quand le club a organisé le
10 sport pour justement connaître
quelque chose une vie que je connaissais
pas du tout on ouvre cette porte tous
types de handicaps et tout type de
handicap peut se mouvoir ici et puis
pouvoir profiter de l'expérience de
geoffrey milan de l'expérience des
coaches qui s'y sont habilités à cette
année dix à vingt joueurs inscrits dont
certains vis des titres nationaux dans
leur catégorie un nombre qui va
augmenter avec la création d'un pôle
handi sport dès septembre prochain
cette structure a pour objectif de
regrouper au même endroit
des jeunes ou moins jeunes qui ont un
potentiel d'intégrer plus ou moins
l'équipe de france à moyen ou long terme
avec possibilité de gérer la scolarité
en même temps symbole de cette réussite
florence siro présidente du club elle
est également en lice pour participer
aux jo paralympiques de tokyo parmi ces
projets une compétition internationale
handisport au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines
ce tournoi va s'inscrire dans de
multiples organisations d'événements et
notamment on souhaiterait pouvoir
organiser le tournoi de qualification
des jeux paralympiques pour paris 2024
le premier sky par att french open qui
devrait rassembler 200 pongiste
handisport aura lieu du 9 au 11 novembre